Bentornata cara vecchia Tokyo è la prima
volta che entro a Tokyo nella nella
storia praticamente che non ho ansia di
niente Mi sembra di essere arrivato a
Milano Malpensa talmente tante volte che
vengo qua ragazzi è spaventoso sono
sceso dall'aereo da un minuto e mezzo
Praticamente sono già sui in metro ormai
so a memoria tutto quello che devo fare
è spavento mi sto spaventando di me
stesso Raga per quanto io sia esperto
questa non me la ricordavo raga Tokyo Si
sta benissimo in questi giorni
te un clima estivo che si sta bene
Venite a Tokyo a giugno
ragazzi non ho fatto la clip dell'hotel
a shibuya perché vabbè veramente tanti
hotel ragazzi che non ha senso fare clip
ogni singola cosa che faccio comunque
questo qua questa è la mia finestra e
questo è quella sopra c'è lo store della
Nintendo quindi sono in piena shibuya la
cosa che fa ridere è che mi affaccio
alla finestra
e ce la Sampdoria comunque Ragazzi è un
lavoro difficile questo però qualcuno
lo doveva fare
adesso cos'è Raga ma cos'è Ma cos'è è
illegale non esiste
Oh porca mi sono cacata nelle
mutande minchia
Una baby Monsters & Company ha catturato
la mia attenzione
ho trovato Pooh Gioia
sono molto contento Questo vlog sta
uscendo fuori clip a caso siamo appunto
si chiama
la pizza ragazzi come sempre prenderò la
pizza Vediamo che succede
cosa devo fare qua qua
uniborosie
la puoi scolare Sì grazie a posto la
potete scolare è buona la scoliamo sì
oh oh oh perfetto
[Musica]
Dai io mi incazzolo ormai
ragazzi siamo a kamakura Abbiamo qua
davanti alla
che Che cazzo è questo questo è un
tempio buddista Sempre gay che rompo le
palle ok perché sennò non so dove andare
piano kamakura ragazzi è una cittadina
vicino al mare quindi a sud di Tokyo
c'ero già stata una volta con Andrea ero
andato a vedere il gigantesco Buddha DJ
quasi c'è in giapponese gigantesco budd
gigantesco ragazzi
[Musica]
no
Ma c'è la bossfight privo che sono under
livellato
anguria
Vabbè comunque che dire
una roba così e comunque ha molto figo
me lo ricordavo più piccolo ovviamente è
molto grosso me lo ricordavo più piccolo
Una frase che mi viene detta spesso fai
Gennaro Facci vedere come si fa treno
Simulator
Oddio ci stanno gente che corre e
conviene frenare
si possono far sì questa stazione
gigantesca Com'è che si esce dalla sua
stazione
[Risate]
Siamo in lista d'attesa per entrare ok
Ha messo il mio nome
è bella eh ragazzi ci porta Maria dove
sei matta Allora ragazzi Qua abbiamo non
so come si chiama non importa
Allora ragazzi Qua abbiamo kaisendon
Queste sono pesci Bianchi adesso pesci
rossi e pesce arancione c'è un cerchio
questo bisogna fare qua dai dobbiamo
togliere sfortuna dobbiamo passare
questo cerchio entrare dentro uscire
sinistro rientra poi sì sì sì sì sì Ehm
One Piece Overture tante altre cose come
come va beh come va poi l'orario 18 26 è
abbastanza nuovo ragazzi Questo è da
scoprire noi siamo Ash paura ok E questo
è il canale non quello YouTube questo è
proprio quello vero Praticamente qua ci
stiamo non so niente che dico cosa
stiamo facendo
la barca si chiama Tokyo water taxi
Tokio Hotel taxi
Scusami chi fa fare un giro turistico
ci sto anch'io ci stanno uccidendo tutti
in maniera abbastanza
giapponese Esatto giapponesi non
salutiamo a un metro di distanza cazzate
invece vedi che funziona Ecco qua il
water taxi con mix tra un pedalò
con i chihuahua
Madonna ragazzi Sai come si dice
italiano
[Musica]
ragazzi Lascia che qualcuno che ha
parcheggiato malissimo potrei essere io
sul Sea of thieve a messa proprio male
alla barca Ma che video vi porto ragazzi
Ma che video vi porto Ma che è ma che è
Ma che roba è Mannaggia No ragazzi sto
facendo un video che non esiste sembra
il tramonto di Evangelion o parte la
sigla di Evangelion Non la mettere
Giampiero che poi ci mettono i cops yoga
[Musica]
che cazzo di rumore lì c'è un tramonto
che non esiste
ok Ha anche una palestra Io ho appena
visto questo gli ho detto questa è
quella cosa di Goku quando si mette
dentro si allenano e mi ha risposto sì
entri qua dentro e ti alleni Adesso mi
deve spiegare che cazzo stai dicendo
esiste veramente quando ha fatto male Sì
è entrato dentro qua hai dormito Non so
tutta la notte Ok poi è uscito fuori è
guarito Perfetto Va bene ragazzi Questo
è un ristorante di sushi a Ginza
Finalmente sono venuto qua perché il
menù è super chiaro e non esattamente
cosa prendere allora Io inizierei con un
piatto di
antipasti per poi concludere con la
lasagna col savoiardo in aggiunta No è
che qua lo fanno qua e poi la crème
brulé No scusa Però alla fragola Insomma
capito buono Allora ragazzi Questa è
l'ultimo punto di Tokyo che ancora non
ho portato in video lo skytree perché
non ci sono mai stato ma cosa divertente
è che sono sbucato dalla metro dentro la
skye 3 cioè dentro lo sky 3 quindi non
so se sono effettivamente non si capisce
se sono dentro o no Quindi adesso uscirò
fuori per vedere se effettivamente sono
dentro lo Sky Tree
Adesso andiamo su a vedere che succede
c'è anche lo store dello Studio Ghibli
ma sto male no bellissimo ragazzi
Sinceramente no vabbè ragazzi fosse lo
store dello Studio Ghibli qua e come
ultima tappa era necessario bellissimo
solo lo studio ghibliqui qua io volevo
venire alla tokiotà Eh sì vabbè vabbè
per la prima volta e sto trovando Robin
incredibile tipo lo Studio Ghibli ehm
Kirby caffè
ma com'è Kirby Ma che senso il Kirby
caffè o meglio io volevo questo
che è incredibile Comunque poi devo fare
un salto così signori
in tutte queste cose che non si spiegano
non so cosa sia quella quella Maxi pera
che c'era giù non si capisce cos'è
quella roba là Oh finalmente questo
ragazzo
solo la posizione della torre
dell'altezza perché non siamo a 350
metri a quanto pare o 300 megapixel non
è alta come la lotta Tower però posso
fare vlog in condizioni così
atroci eh Siamo in aeroporto e stiamo
per imbarcarci non stanco morto mi sono
alzato alle 5 lo proviamo la Lounge di
Japan Airlines che è già qualcosa la
cosa incredibile ragazzi Questa cosa è
assurda E che il mio posto è lo stesso
della che avevo su ita Airways solo che
questo non su Japan Airlines ma è
localizzato nello stesso punto
incredibile Questa cosa non so con
quanta probabilità poteva succedere una
cosa del genere ma veramente molto poco
già ha ficcato lo zaino dove non dovrei
mettere me ne fotto all'apparenza sembra
più piccola stranamente quella di Japan
Airline però non ho idea di cosa abbia
da offrirci quindi vediamo alla fine
sono tanti fattori che contano promesso
in realtà non esperto di business Class
anche qui ragazzi subito in partenza Mi
hanno offerto dello champagne o del
succo d'arancia Io ho scelto ovviamente
il succo d'arancia per agevolare un bel
po' di reflusso gastroesofageo durante
il volo bene il posto mi sembra molto mi
sembra è più lungo di quello di vita
Airways sono un po' più stretto e questo
è il rame il ragazzo che ci hanno
servito al pranzo cena durante il volo
mentre che avevo la febbre perché Sì mi
è venuta la febbre nel mentre che ero in
volo quindi non mi sono goduto così
tanto la business Class al ritorno
perché stavo morendo ma meno male che
ero in business Class perché se fossi
stato in economy saremo morto E come
potete sentire dalla mia voce non sto
ancora bene purtroppo sono passati tre o
quattro giorni da quando sono tornato in
Italia nonostante questo farò lo stesso
la chiusa perché ci tengo Perdonatemi se
mi sentite così è stato un viaggio
incredibile è finito abbiamo finito ok
questa era la fine ho viaggiato in
Giappone praticamente negli ultimi due
mesi Io sto facendo questi viaggi ve lo
Vabbè ve lo dico anche perché ho bisogno
di scoprire me stesso un po' di più ma
poi vi spiegherò perché sostanzialmente
tutto quello che mi è successo negli
ultimi 10 anni la mia carriera
sostanzialmente mi ha portato a
chiedermi oggi un po' chi sono ok Quindi
sto viaggiando parecchio anche per
trovare
risposte però prima forse dovrei
prendere un po' di Tachipirina mi
parlerò di questo in un altro video
voglio parlarvi di questo è una cosa
molto introspettiva che sto per ve ne
parlerò volevo concludere dicendo che
tutti questi video sono stati splendidi
da far per girarli voglio dire spero
anche per voi vederli Mi sono divertito
tantissimo questo è un periodo della mia
vita che tra qualche anno ricorderò e
dirò Porca vacca che bel periodo perché
molto spesso noi ci ci ricordiamo delle
cose belle pensando al passato ma non ci
ricordiamo di viverci il presente quindi
sto cercando di vivermi presente volevo
ringraziarvi per avermi seguito in tutta
questo percorso ci rivediamo con i
prossimi video Ci sono tante cose che
voglio fare tra parentesi tra un po' vi
porterò ovviamente Outlast che è uscito
quando io sono partito quindi non potevo
farlo ma ve lo porterò tranquilli
ragazzi e vi porterò anche tantissime
altre cose che ho in mente ma non vi
posso spoilerare nulla comunque ci
vediamo nel prossimo video ragazzi
Grazie per aver seguito questo viaggio
vado a prendermi una pastiglia per la
gola e noi ci vediamo ad un prossimo
video bella ragazzi